The Office of the National Coordinator for health information technology,
or ONC, administers the HIT certification program.
It is voluntary, and includes capabilities such as recording,
security, and interoperable sharing of health information.
As shown here, the program defines the technical requirements for health IT,
and the process by which commercial systems may become and remain certified.
Commercial authorized testing labs do the testing
using ONC provided criteria and test data sets.
Since hospitals and providers must acquire a certified EHR to receive incentive payments,
it's virtually a business necessity for EHR vendors to be certified.
ONC reports on its progress on it's HIT dashboard site.
This graphic from that site shows that as of July 2016,
632 vendors supplied certified health I.T.
to 337432 ambulatory primary care and specialist
physicians and other providers participating in the Medicare EHR incentive program.
While EPIK systems supply certified technology to 30 percent of all those providers,
there are 632 vendors in total,
something that clearly exacerbates the interoperability challenge.
Here you see that as of July 2016 175 certified vendors supplied systems
to 4474 nonfederal acute care hospitals
participating in the Medicare EHR incentive program.
This market is far more concentrated,
as only ten vendors supplied about 98 percent of hospitals.
But interoperability is still an issue among hospitals.
The reasons are not limited to technology:
too many hospitals and health systems seek to control access to
their digital records to make it convenient and hence more
likely that patients will obtain all their care from one source.
Importantly the top three vendors listed here have all announced support for
fire and smart on fire as an EHR connected platform for fire apps,
including those written by third parties.
This liberation of EHR data for innovative purposes may not be classic interoperability,
but it could lead to progress in solving some of
the EHR challenges we'll discuss later on in this lesson.